one of the simplest if not the best ways
to do a proportional system is to have
voters simply put an X next to their
favorite party and then you take those
results from the citizens votes and you
try to match your representatives to
that as closely as possible given the
number of seats that you have in your
legislative branch but one of the
philosophical problems that you might
have with such a system is that the
citizens aren't voting for individuals
in particular they're voting for the
party in general and what that means is
there needs to be a meeting that happens
somewhere at the party headquarters
where they determine who their favorite
candidates are and so when the monkey
party gets told that they have three
seats they have already made a list of
who gets the first seat the second seat
and the third seat proportional systems
do have the advantage that their
explicit goal is to try to match the
legislative branch of the government as
closely as possible to how the citizens
have voted STV is a bit of a
proportional ish system proportionality
is not its goal its goal is actually
trying to make sure that as many
citizens as possible have local
representatives that they voted for and
also to minimize the number of unhappy
voters and as a side effect you get a
roughly proportional legislature but not
exactly